partiamo col piede giusto prima di tutto
se non disponibile manco siri ad aprire
trofei spese perfetta lo apro io da
partenza
meglio di così non potevo immaginarlo
ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
avessero bio sono vari geni siamo
tornati su traffici quest voi non lo
sapete ma da questo qua sono io
questo tizio qualche carica la mattina
sono io il problema è che sta cagando in
mutande faccia da troll sghignazzante ha
scritto una domanda ce l'avrei anch'io
perché ora ragazzi se va su trophies
questo video memes che sarebbe il
continuo dell'ultimo trophies quest me
l'hai detto tu cosa devo fare somiglia
ceo scorri ma che schifo se fissato
nella tuta da una parte qual è il senso
importante che non si cada addosso
ragazzi ma così va ancora pensiamo a
livello due ragazzi che ancora che bello
sto tizio
ecco questo non mi rispecchia perché mi
hanno stato notato una mail mai faccio
azie
avevo sbucciarle ma papà che la stagione
ceo stai perdendo la pelle che castorini
cioè non è un ragazzo che ha vinto io su
carta posso fare una domanda a me va
bene che ci sia una festa che siano
tutti contenti ma perché cazzo c'è una
gallina dietro il televisore qual è il
problema zio perché
ma ci sono legali né nascoste perché è
partito screen sentite one direction
cosa devo fare io li prendo perché non
ho capito o cea posso prendere la testa
della metto la metto su di lui ma anche
farci daft punk
adesso che sei un dj di fama mondiale
possa avviare sull'aereo prima ronaldo
l'america col casco si col casco di mesi
un dj forza bravissimo o fanta ecco
questo ragazzi sono io agli appuntamenti
io la tipa incazzata che l'altro sta al
telefono fantastico ed altro zio non è
tanto che usi un cellulare mentre sei un
appuntamento il problema è che se è un
appuntamento in ciabatte non voglio
sapere perché ecco è morto il telefono a
noi molto lui chiamò alternativo vota
buttiamo la clip a ciò che succede mi
deve fare una spiaggia questo caso fa
vola vabbè ho capito se l'avevo detto
un'ora prima bisognava portarla nativa
ma lo sapevo io ad un appuntamento
ragazzi se la ragazza [ __ ]
perché dovete posare il telefono a
posate la ragazza che un video ma che
voi sappiate gli elefanti e fanno questi
rumori no perché non me li ricordavo
così a devo muovere lui fantastico aveva
lasciate perfetto ragazzi sto video fa
miliardi di views e vai a vario tipo
come contento brava tra i big money ha
già capito tutto il tipo che i ragazzi
siamo in doccia cosa vuoi
ok sto sono io scemo sono io scemo
cosa c'è quel problema ed ho capito
scusa devo chiudere la tenda era certo
old troll cosa vuol dire ora che ti sei
lavato zio posso togliere il non so
perché sia diventato nero perché un
cavallo è livello successivo bloccato
guadagna più troller per sbloccare i
livelli a stona troll eto'o salto mossa
del trolley miniera del trash ma
spiegatemi perché ci sono dei minigiochi
effetto salto per l'amor di dio
vai al gioco fate fai un pezzo quando
nessuno ti guarda ma perché ragazzi
bello a me amalgama tomas chiamato
pazienza e io con questa cosa qua
guadagno dei troll che ne so io quando
si gira la tipa abbiamo pagato per terra
fantastica se è morta ragazzi appena ci
sono vecchia soldi scorregge fantastico
questo è cagato completamente addosso
per adesso facciamo gli altri poi appena
troveremo ci sono ma don pieno sono
sette miliardi di livelli che non ha
rinunciato invero mai però ora come ora
va bene così ragazzi andiamo al ix
livello che oddio in primis ho trovato
la gallina che non so se vuol male
qualcosa no che è morgan in versione un
po più afroamericana però è morgan
sarebbe the voice starà quixa chicco
lati palco per tipo col berretto mi
chiami name scorta si canta bello
crolla yen dopo trolley m io posso
concludere il cesr ragazzi non ho parole
è problemi ha fatto infatti miscelare
morgan perché non ho capito che tarlati
fa eco morgan si è esaltato tron jones
ma non era morgan abbia pazienza e poi
c'è questa tizia coi capelli neri mette
un metallaro
trolley j trolley j tra licei che
dovrebbe essere gesti j però mi sa che
tra licei nel mio video non è che
proprio non sia al massimo e non so
aiuti
[Applauso]
ma dava questa la canzone dei troni
direi che con questo ha convinto tutti
fantastico questo ragazzo è un tipico
ambiente familiare col padre che rimane
a casa col bambino ma c'è un'altra
gallino io trovo le galline ragazzo rom
atroce tossica forte marsica forte amico
mio tu non mangi to mastichi forte non
riesce a chiudere la bocca dalla chiesa
mesi ha vissuto lasciato il dito ma l'ha
addirittura nave mavi chiesa gelatissimo
ho vinto l'importante questo cos'è sta
roba come fermare la locomotiva ragazzi
mettiamo un piede ma posso mettere piede
anno al piede lo è il suo high pensavo
che c'è ma è giusto lo metti giù
mettiamo i piccioni famiglia s'è
schiantato sul treno aveva poi c'è un
troll che non ho capito cosa lascia il
fronte passa il treno ai 3.000 allora
che venga il tipo col piede e geniale
vabbè andiamo sulla gallina prima di
tutto perfetto allora addio anch'io mi
sentivo figo quando facciamo sta cosa
con le macchinine per avevo tre anni c'è
una netta per deco esatto
cosa devo fare ma mi muore per terra e
che cosa devo fare spiegano devo tener
premuto andare in basso il che non si
spacca il coccige fammi capire sotto
l'infini nel culo e cosa perfette modo
migliore per rimorchiare le donne non
esiste complimenti salve dovrebbe essere
una youtuber di mail che sei certo
perfetta eyeliner questo cosa che non so
che cos'è la matita che bella che sei
perché piangi perché piangi sei
bellissima ma cosa c'è una gallina
dietro sé aveva una gallina dietro
l'orecchio
dietro l'orecchio anche io ogni tanto mi
sveglio mi controllo dietro l'orecchio
ciò le galline
ah ecco le teche la soluzione era alle
te e lo sapevo io devo tipica corse o
dio questo cos'è un appello
adesso se veramente magliocca paura o
togliere anche questo la palla che ha
una pala in faccia bellissima voi non
avete capito un cazzo del make up
adesso vi segnalo fare andate là lo zio
gesualdo che abita in cascina prendete
la pala che c'è in cantina dateve lei
faccia e siete a posto ma veramente a
posto c è chi cazzo è justin bieber è
chiaro ragazzuoli concluso più per
questa volta perché ce ne sono mille
guardo visto ci vado avanti nel prossimo
anche se sarà un pò un casino sbloccare
gli altri livelli però ricordatevi che
avete imparato una cosa da questo video
come truccarvi anche voi maschietti come
al solito seguito è piaciuto lasciate un
commento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook come nei video tra tante
iscrizioni sono sentiti scalatrici
migliaio roma sorrido bello ragazzo ma
dov'è ma non mi raccomando questo è
tanto è tutto un troll sto vito d'aria